do you ever find yourself overwhelmed by
emotion yes yes it does happen
Lydia Tara the character and obviously
tar the film what is so incredible about
it as a huge classical musical fan that
I am you open with her CV and in
instantly if you're me you're like this
is a superhero you've just described
Superman Superwoman this is incredible
but the story is so real and and I would
say lived in and authentic and has very
I would say present themes and it exists
and I think that Fantastical but
realistic way and I know that was a
balance that both UK and Todd set from
the beginning so how did you sort of
create it that way within this again it
the choice of the Mauler everything from
your conducting coach it's so real but
then in so many ways it's fantastical
well it is still a fairy tale in that
there's not a female running a major
German Orchestra so in that way we can
take a there's a lot of poetic license
to talk about to Trojan Horse a lot of
really big questions I think that that
we were both been thinking about but
it's interesting you talk about that
that CV because the genius of what Todd
wrote is that you have the CV and you're
thinking wow my Lord and then you see
her assistant
mouthing the CD knowing that this whole
thing is managed so you realize that
there is a kind of a there's some form
of a manipulation there from from the
get-go so this is not going to be you're
not asked to look at this character
through rose-colored glasses right from
the very beginning yeah I was going to
say Todd I think you kind of set that up
from the beginning but I would have to
say I don't I think there's a lot of
films that don't hold up to classical
scrutiny and this film is absolutely one
that does and so I know that it has to
come from craftsmanship and from
stakeholders that helped you so talk
about how you created even with Kate in
mind but how you created Lydia tar from
Whole scratch
um well I mean there's there are two
components one is the the character
um of Lydia tar and the other one of
course is to sort of milieu that you
know you're that you're talking about
the classical milieu which in truth I
didn't know a great deal about you know
so um I had to do my homework
um and uh Kate and I would both agree
that probably neither one of us really
wants to trot out our homework because
it's just the Practical things that you
have to do to to to do your job but
um I would be remiss in not calling out
John Mount Cherry who was sort of my um
sort of uh teacher uh gave me a course
study in terms of a crash course in
terms of these are the things you want
ought to know and these are the things
you might want to pay attention to and
also being there is a great sounding
board for me in terms of talking about
uh turns in the script and would this be
plausible and under what sort of
circumstances in terms of the character
um you know I'd always imagine this sort
of um this child you know who uh came
from sort of uh very particular
circumstances
um
uh that she wanted to escape and that
you know her her sort of escape hatch
was uh being introduced to this music
through a very particular way
um and and and so she ran towards that
escape hatch you know um and she had
dreams in the way that uh you know and I
think in many ways only someone that's
so far away from where she finally winds
up actually would allow themselves to
dream I don't think that many people
that were that grow up with classical
music as a part of their family lives or
a part of their the world that they live
in would ever allow themselves to
believe that Lydia Tark that they
themselves could be at the top of an
orchestra such as this would have to be
somebody that was so far away from it
that would allow themselves to to
actually believe they could get there
and the steps in which they take to get
there are many and um
and uh so you start out with with a
character that is so driven by salvation
through ART and salvation through
creation and and um and they feel alive
making noise
um and they find themselves turning 50
um and now this small child is now a
middle-aged person who has achieved so
much that they're looking at their life
in the rear view mirror and and and they
start making decisions based on the fact
that they're looking at their life in
the rearview mirror and it's interesting
to see those decisions and how they sort
of like play out within your character
um I think for folks like myself who are
a huge fan of Leonard Bernstein like
this is such a great I think companion
piece in so many ways but what what
Inspirations did you draw upon your
advisors the physical I think
manifestations even of what you do with
tar and this are incredible she
literally holds herself like a conductor
but well that's great great
um
um I
there were many things I had to get to
I'd get granular really quickly with um
you know the obviously the conducting
and and had to pick up the piano again
which I hadn't played since I was a girl
and all of these things just so that I
could play the scenes
um and so that the audience because it's
a it's a rehearsal film it's it's not a
performance film and so the way and
talking to conductors um you know in
preparation and subsequent to making the
movie The Way One conducts in rehearsal
is entirely different to the way you
actually the show that you put on when
when you're in performance or when
you're recording for instance and I
started with because the pandemic was on
so the the the chance to be face to face
with people wasn't alive to me wasn't
possible I started with um Ilya musson's
master classes you know went back right
back to the genius source and I have
friend a friend who fortunately had some
time who was a conductor Natalie Murray
Beale to then
um you know talk about you know just the
the beating structure you know the the
time keeping and and the kind of the
emotional psychological shaping that you
got to get the um you know the the the
phrasing and the the color you know and
so all of that stuff it's a bit you know
a bit like this which I had to you know
I had to learn but I did understand
um and I was grateful to having spent
many many decades on stage so I
understood
I I understood breath you know to
inspire
um is you know that's where the
inspiration comes from and so you have
to breathe and you have to and Bernstein
as you would know says that you know the
the inhalation is the inspiration and
the out breath there's the music so
um that I kind of understood so there
were some kind of basic principles that
I felt I could transpose from being an
actor on stage
um and having a very strong relationship
to to audience but um you know there
were I think nothing could have prepared
us all but but for me personally
standing on the podium in front of the
um The Dresden philharmony because once
the once you give the downbeat and the
music comes back at you you could have
listened to Von carrion and gegeeff and
um Simone young and Natalie stutzman and
um Laurent eclube play all of these
great works and who think you understand
their music but you don't understand the
music until it comes through you and
back at you with an orchestra and that
was something that I will never ever
forget it was profound
just got a bit of chill so thank you for
that
um very much uh that was incredible Todd
I will also say in addition to the
technical achievement of this film the
language that you put within it like I
said I am not a master but I think it's
going to hold up to those scrutinies but
in choosing Kate I know you said that
she was really the only person that
could play this role having seen it I
agree but what about the character as
you were crafting it made it essentially
and I would say from its Inception her
role and why did you know that she would
be the one person that could really
bring life to this I think very
complicated character
um well Kate and I started uh um we met
um Kate has different ideas about this
she claims we've met um years before but
I I think she's we met years ago in the
Four Seasons Hotel and I met you and you
were so just interested in me and it's
like was the most horrendous meaning but
then we met again 10 days later and I
pretend I ignored that meeting which you
said never happened and then we were
talking about where we never met when
she says we met we met 10 years ago um I
I Joan Diddy and and I had had been
working on a script for about a year
um and I I asked Kate if she would meet
to talk about it and we and we did we
met here in New York
um I think we met in this hotel no we
met downtown at the Crosby um see we're
never going to agree we had dinner she
had a lovely suit on I remember wide
Pinstripes brown suit um and uh out of
that conversation that the film didn't
happen but what I was struck out of that
conversation by was aside from Kate's
formidable
um uh career and her incredible skill as
a performer just the intelligence uh
that she has um and the and the the way
that she looks at an idea that
conversation really um echoed and
resonated with me
um and I was desperate to collaborate
with her after that and I I had been
thinking for a long time what would that
be and so when I started writing this
I've never written for an actor before
ever
um because I I think it's dangerous and
potentially very limiting to the actor
because it's based on other things
you've seen them do or uh on the
character themselves so there's always a
sort of gray masked person that I'm
thinking about I never can see them but
but based on that on that meeting that
we had together it was clear that that
it was Kate and I wanted to be able to
collaborate with her um because I wanted
to be able to have some big
conversations about some questions that
that the script was was sort of begging
um to have so um she didn't know I was
writing it for her
um and um and I was really frightened to
send it to her because that she said no
you know I I I I wouldn't have made the
film so um lucky me you know um lucky us
okay thank you for saying yes
I'm worried I'm starting to disappear
into herself
you want to dance the mask you must
service the composer you've got to
supplement yourself your ego and yes
your identity
Nina I'm going to start with you because
it is a film that definitely I think
examines uh how we lionize people and
canonize people and sometimes we can be
complicit in that and I'm just wondering
over the course of making it did you
ever as an actor sort of think that
because it is it is something that we I
think we all can kind of wrestle with
watching this movie in the current and
the current moment about how we canonize
people on their accomplishments even if
they're not Sometimes the best people
well it went I definitely thought about
it because that is also the relationship
Sharon my character has with with Lydia
because she truly I believe admires her
as a musician and really and as a person
of course she falls in love with her but
but through that really I think that
they they are able to create this
amazing music together and she wants
Lydia to be able to do that in the most
free way possible people and for that
she is willing to do a lot of groundwork
for her so that she has a calm entry
point and can just do what she's best at
but also of course both characters are
part of a of a system that you have to
navigate in and someone who is such an
incredible light
figure of course has a lot of power and
I was thinking a lot about who are the
people around that character do you
enhance certain actions do you for your
own good you know or or yeah who keeps
the system up
and and that was so interesting for me
to work on with Sharon and to see that
it's because she's no one's really
innocent and uh you know in in all of
that and yeah that was fascinating yeah
that's very true there are no innocent
parties in this one um and I even Sophie
with Olga I would say like of anyone she
is definitely thrust into it and you
could even say that but even in that
there's uh there's a certain level of
everybody I think can be complicit
around these actors but in the same
respect I'll have to ask you like
starting to do a movie like this it's uh
at your point in your career I would
imagine it's even more different because
it's essentially like you're like oh God
don't be that at the end of it how did
you feel about these figures after you
sort of made the film
I mean I think
um
what I was
uh really fascinated by was that you
know Olga sees it you never really know
quite where where she stands you don't
quite know if she's just oblivious to
this all or if she's you know she's
calculating and scheming but I really
think you you see her push back and you
know she doesn't she doesn't Bend and
she she knows that she's going to do it
her own way and she's not going to fall
into this this trap and it was
really I guess empowering to play a
character who just you know sticks to
her guns and just isn't going to be
messed around and
um kind of succeeds despite everything
but um there's also this very playful
side to Olga which was just lovely to
play and it's nice to have these scenes
that kind of break up the tension in the
movie some of them didn't make it to cut
as well that were even more kind of
young and
careless oh she's entering adulthood so
she's still very much on the boundary
and you see that a lot in the film and
that was quite fun as well so yeah yeah
her childlike approach to literally kind
of every aspect of both composition
music everything that she sort of does
just from the way that she sort of
approaches it is such a stark contrast
to what Kate is doing she's so Stern and
serious and so you can see the literal
attraction and the Opposites but for
both of you I'm nervous because you
after you guys I get to talk to Kaden
like I'm not I've done it a couple of
times now I've not gotten any better at
it but I just have to remember that
she's just a lovely a lovely person you
know I love extremely talented but she's
just the lovely warm no normal kind of
person I mean she's amazing she's a
she's a genius but she is a just a
lovely lovely person yeah oh no she's
always great it's my side that sort of
lets it down but I would ask yeah what
was it as far as working with her like
because both as
Kate Blanchett the person acting in the
scene but then also as Lydia tar the
character in every scene in the movie
everyone really has to turn their
attention to her she has to command a
presence and then as both actors and
people you have to portray that on
screen but I think obviously as people
you're probably feeling it in real life
so talk about that sort of dichotomy of
living in that on set and me and I'll
start with you well for me it's just it
it's just incredibly inspiring to work
with an actor like that you know because
she
like you said she is
demanding she's she is she takes the
scene and her character to places that
are surprising that are daring the
choices she makes they are bold and
they're exciting uh and unexpected and
it is just such fun to work with that
you know because that gives you the
opportunity to react on such a strong uh
a statement that she does in every
moment you know and I was very curious
to see what she would do with with Lydia
and certain things because Sharon is not
part of the way the whole time
I thought oh that's an interesting
choice I don't quite understand but I
guess there is something happening
before and Ireland and she has it all
planned out and things and it is so
amazing to see now uh when you watch the
film how fine she with having all these
different moments how multifaceted her
players it's just stunning and it's so
she she's got she's got a certain uh
control over it and just enough you know
that it's also free and and she can
react and flow with the partners also
you know but she has she's in control of
what she does and that is us just
fascinating and gift yeah and a gift to
watch literally it literally a masterful
to watch and everywhere and then Sophie
again this is your first film which I in
no way I found that out reading the
Press notes and I literally read it
twice because I couldn't believe that
information
but I love that you're now able to be
like giving me my courage like it's
she's fine but come on girl that first
day walking on set you can't pretend no
no I'll be I'll be truly honest with you
the first time I met her we were doing a
rehearsal like with the with the
um her the person who taught her to
conduct Natalie Murray Beal and I
remember it was like two floors so I
heard her come in downstairs and I heard
her voice and I was just like
I am hallucinating because you know I've
grown up seeing her on my TV screen my
whole life and being like a huge admirer
of her work and I remember she was like
hi I'm Kate Blanchard nice to meet you
I'm like
I know
hi I think I didn't I didn't really
speak very much for the the first five
minutes because I just didn't really
kind of know how to act and then I had
to play for as well which was super
scary but I quickly learned that she is
one of the like I said kindest warmest
most encouraging people I have met she
really helped me a lot when we were
filming and was always coming with
suggestions and she was so supportive
and encouraging
unlike Olga and Lydia or I guess Lydia
sees Olga
or she sees her younger self and us and
Olga and she kind of Olga becomes
somewhat of a muse for tar's Creative
Energy and so they have that kind of and
of course Olga looks up to her as the
amazing conductor that she is so it was
amazing to be able to learn from Kate
and then to be able to pass on a little
bit of musical knowledge as well you
know the kind of two-sided way oh yeah I
don't know how to say but um I I learned
a lot from her and I felt very honored
that I was like allowed to pass on a
little bit of knowledge as well but um I
I just
um felt so lucky to work with this
amazing cast and director and crew and I
just had a amazing time really